if you just upgraded to one of the new
iPhone 14 models or you're thinking
about buying one then you definitely
need to buy a case to protect it and
that's why I have so many cases right in
front of me so what I'm going to do in
this video is go through some of the top
cases that we've used for the iPhone 14
lineup and tell you why we like them and
it's not only going to be me because the
other co-host Max also has some top
picks for cases that he likes himself so
he's going to do the second part of this
video now the first case I want to get
into is the snap case from moft and the
reason we chose this one because it has
by far the strongest magnets out of any
case out there just check this out I'm
going to show you how strong these are
it could literally lift up this charging
stand just like that watch compared to a
competitor's case where the magnets are
just not as strong and the main reason
why that's important is because if
you're going to be using Mac safe
accessories like the the moft wallet
like I always daily carry this has a
very very strong connection so that's
great for all your macsafe accessories
so of course you'll find a link to it
down below just like all the other cases
I'm going to show you in this video now
moving on to the next case we have this
nice leather case from Toro but it's
actually not fully leather because on
the inside it's basically like a nice
silicone case however they have a slab
of leather all around right on the back
which basically gives it a nice feel and
by the way this is genuine leather
stitched right to the back and of course
they have the camera bump protectors
over here so if that's something you're
into you can check out one of these two
colors using the link below and I
definitely like this leather feel while
you have the grip of the silicone on the
sides now moving on to the next one we
actually have a ton of cases from the
sponsor of this video encased and by the
way each one of these cases comes with a
screen protector in the box which is a
huge value in all these cases range from
about 15 to 20 ish bucks so they're in
incredibly good value now the nice thing
about these cases is that all of them
are very rugged and durable so they're
going to protect your iPhone even down
to the translucent transparent case and
it even goes up to one like this that is
insanely rugged with a built-in
kickstand and a built-in protector on
the front they can also get very simple
like this nice silicone case which has
this nice felt material on the inside or
if you're a lady you can get this
classic one and they also have ones like
this which actually has a built-in
wallet with multiple areas for your ID
your cards and even a lanyard and this
one actually covers the front of the
iPhone as well with some compartments
for cash cards everything they've also
got this one which you could literally
slot in credit cards and it has a little
spring to hold it in this one right here
has a nice little band so you can just
grip it like this this so overall with
these cases from encased I'm surprised
by the build quality so check out the
link down in the description and pin
comment below and now those first few
cases out of the way I'm going to turn
it over to Max
all right guys so you know that I'm not
a fan of thick big cases I know that
some people like them they serve a
purpose but personally this is my
favorite case it's the pataka mag easy
case 3 which is made from 100 genuine
aramid fibers and that is what
bulletproof vests are made of so you
literally have that on your phone now
not only does it look super cool but I
loved last year's version because of how
thin it was and I don't know how but the
updated version is 33 thinner and 27
lighter being less than one millimeter
thick so it is the thinnest and lightest
Max save compatible case in the world
now with that you still have protection
on all four corners and you have this
raised camera lip to protect your lenses
they also have a few densities to choose
from or if you want a little bit of pop
like me they have their Fusion weave
technology which is literally colored
fibers sewn in instead of like many
companies that just do a painted print
on top now some people love the design
but they want more protection so that is
why they made the mag easy case Pro 3
which isn't that much thicker or heavier
but it uses TPU for air pockets for that
shock resistance and it has full
coverage all around and they also
seamlessly fuse the aramid fibrous and
the TPU together which I guess is
extremely hard to do which is why most
brands don't do that at all and you have
gaps now the next one isn't as nice but
it is also super thin which I love this
is totally's ultra slim minimal case now
I don't know if you guys can see that
obviously this one's partially
translucent they have different colors
but it is insanely thin I'm not sure the
material it's made from it's not going
to give you that crazy drop protection
but it does have this camera lip that's
a little bit tougher so it will protect
your camera lenses and then with that
you do have a little bit of a raised
Edge on the front but this thing is like
almost not having anything at all you
guys see how thin that is compared to
the phone itself it weighs nothing so if
you want a little bit of protection from
scratches on your stainless steel on the
back and protect your lenses but you
don't want something that's going to add
extra thickness heaviness anything like
that extra width so if you want
something minimal I don't think it gets
any more minimal than this now they also
have one which is slightly thicker it is
still a lot thinner than other cases
that are this style this is a flexible
version so you get a little bit added
grip because the material is different
and you get that full clear you know
kind of design but with that it is still
nice thin and minimal so we'll add a lot
of heft to your device now if you want
something that has a little bit more
protection some more features and
actually a lower price we have ESR gears
classic kickstand case here so as you
guys could see it has the maxafe magnets
built in they call it Halo lock it has
stronger mag safe than regular Apple
cases not as strong as the moff case but
still nice and strong it has these
bumpers and they say it has military
grade protection that's a little bit
thicker because of that a little bit
less flexible and the really cool thing
is that it has a kickstand built in in
the actual camera bump that you need to
have there to protect your lenses it
doubles up as that so typically what you
would have is like this Taurus case
which is also not bad and my dad loves
this case as this big kickstand that's
strong but it gives you an extra bump
over here a little extra thickness extra
weight so why not have that built in to
your camera right there so you can set
it up at an angle you can watch videos
and then close it up this thing is all
metal so it is durable now of course one
thing with these clear cases is it's
really hard to avoid those fingerprints
on them they really pop out especially
with you know a color like my red here
so if you want something that won't have
that issue and it will give you even
more protect section we have the nilkin
cam Shield slim now I bought this case
for one reason and then I saw some other
great reasons to have it and that is the
fact that it has that camera Shield so
most cases almost all of them have your
cameras exposed now they'll have that
lip which this one actually has a lip
that sticks out even more so because you
have the sliding thing but what about
when you drop it and it was a rock on
the ground right if you were
construction or whatever you're doing
you need the extra durability bam you
close that sucker up and now no matter
what it falls on your lenses are
completely protected now with that this
thing is a killer value and the quality
feels a lot nicer than I expected for
that price it is very durable your phone
stays in there like crazy I'm talking
about it's kind of a pain to take it off
I mean you could do it obviously but it
really grips your phone it has a decent
raised lip all around how has these
bumpers right here the buttons actually
pressed surprisingly easily so even
though I bought it mostly for this
feature right here uh I think overall
for the price it is a great case now for
this last one I don't know how much you
guys are going to like it and when I
first saw it I was like why would
somebody even make that up but my wife
loved it so this is the zve zipper case
it's very inexpensive surprisingly and
as you guys could see it literally has a
zipper on here so while most uh cases
you know they'll have a couple things
for cards maybe on the back this one has
a bunch of slots it literally has these
sections that pop out and you literally
zip it up so my wife has used one of
these for a little over a year now and
now this is for the 14 pro Max and she
throws change in there or receipts
whatever else zips up and you are not
going to lose whatever you put in there
holds on nice you have some protection
all around buttons not too bad to press
at all I think they have some different
colors that last year she had one that
was slightly different and of course if
you drop this sucker well when you're
gonna drop it you're gonna go like this
it gives extra protection against the
lenses because you have this fat thing
sticking out here now they also do give
you this little lanyard so if you want
to use a lanyard you could do that it
also has RFID protection for your cards
so it's not something that I would want
to use because I keep my phones in my
pocket but for my wife that doesn't
anyways a lot of ladies they have tiny
Pockets this is something that works out
really well for them so there you guys
go those are our top cases we chose
brands that we like we chose cases that
stand out because they have some unique
features some are really low price some
are more on the premium and a little bit
more expensive but obviously you have a
lot of materials that cost a lot more
money to make
um so you guys let me know if you guys
have you know other cases or which ones
you guys liked the best go ahead and
click that Circle above if you guys want
to subscribe if you guys enjoyed this
video check out one of those right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]